I never say never to anything believe me
babies included cuz surprise Cameron
Diaz and Benji Madden just welcomed a
baby girl on Friday the couple announced
the news on Instagram sharing this
message that read in part quote we are
so happy blessed and grateful to begin
this new decade by announcing the birth
of our daughter
radix Madden she has instantly captured
our hearts and completed our family
Cameron and Benji also explained that
they have no plans to share any pictures
of their little one and won't be giving
any more details about her in order to
protect her privacy but they did add
that they're sweet bundle of joy is
quote really really cute some would even
say rad the actress and the rocker tied
the knot in 2015 in a private ceremony
I'm just grateful for you know my family
my friends my health those are the
really the most important things since
then the two have stayed tight-lipped
about their love but the 47 year old was
unusually candid about her marriage in a
rare interview with InStyle magazine in
2019 calling getting married the best
thing that ever happened to me
she also called Benji the greatest human
being and my great partner she added
quote marriage is certainly hard and
it's a lot of work you need somebody
who's willing to do the work with you
because there's no 60/40 in marriage
it's 50/50 period all the time Cameron
admitted that she didn't know if she was
ready to get married when she did but
she knew that Benji was special quote
he's just a good man there's no bullet
it's really refreshing I'm grateful for
him my motto is gratitude beyond the
attitude and I live that every day
[Music]